[Musique]
cher journal
je me demande pourquoi parler quand on
peut ne rien dire allô oui c'est fait
ils m'appellent maman ma mère m'appelle
trois fois par jour pour me dire qu'elle
n'a pas du tout le temps et qu'elle me
rappelle plus tard pour économiser
quelques mots elle m'écrit des messages
codés que j'ai appris avec le temps à
déchiffrer
elle sait tout sans que je ne raconte
rien je sais ce qu'elle va me dire avant
même qu'elle n'ait me disais comme elle
sait que je sais bah du coup il ne dit
rien mais on se comprend sans se parler
on n'a pas tellement besoin de mots pour
communiquer
[Musique]
les silences ne sont pas quand les
esprits sont connectés
il
mais arrête avec ça j'ai pas envie
d'aller chez le coiffeur je vais te le
dire tous les jours où j'ai pas du tout
dit ça t'a pas dit ça c'est pas ça que
tu as dis là
la seule pensée qu elle verbalise sans
arrêt c'est que je devrais me mettre au
sport que j'ai les cheveux ternes et mr
fatigué
[Musique]
nous
maman je suis un peu précis je vais y
aller à pied le coup mais ça va aller
attention ça va donner
je t'appelle ce soir visuellement vise
haut alors je dis que je ne termine
jamais rien aux mamans mais j'espère que
tu n'auras jamais fini de me parler sans
rien dire n'arrête jamais de me dire que
j'ai une sale tête que je devrais aller
chez le coiffeur
parce que ce que je vais écrire ne va
pas te plaire moment mais je n'aurais
jamais fini de thé mais oui encore un
truc que je ne terminerai pas mais c'est
comme ça c'est tout fait avec maman tu
que je te dise rien pour ma voie là et
n'oublie pas d'aller chez le coiffeur
[Musique]